.
Ich habe Tränen in den Augen.
Es war ...
... schön in der Schweiz.
Wenn ich sehe, wo wir jetzt sind,
muss ich sagen, dass wir
sehr viel dafür tun mussten.
Wir jammern sehr viel.
* Sie imitiert ein Wolfsheulen. *
Was meinst du mit Jammern?
Wir jammern nicht, das sind facts.
Wir wussten doch,
dass es nicht einfach werden würde.
Sie alle gingen auf und davon.
Ihr Ziel:
die Erfüllung eines grossen Traums.
Familie Caboussat zog an die Nordsee
wegen eines
denkmalgeschützten Wasserturms.
Dianne und Marco Schommer
bauten einen Fitnessklub in Ruanda.
Und Corinne und Ralf Waldburger
planten ein Hundehotel
im sonnigen Spanien.
Wie geht es den Auswanderern heute?
Wunderschön.
Wir haben sie ein Jahr später
noch einmal besucht.
* Lässige Popmusik *
# Uf u dervo!
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Möwenschreie, Kinderstimmen *
Herbst an der Costa Blanca.
Anders als in der Schweiz heisst das
Badewetter und Sonnenschein.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Seit fast zwei Jahren
leben Corinne und Ralf Waldburger
in Benissa im Südosten Spaniens.
Die Wege für den Spaziergang
sind vertraut
und mittlerweile kennen sie
auch die eine oder andere Nachbarin.
* Sie spricht spanisch. *
(Spanisch)
Wir haben sie schon lange
nicht mehr gesehen, was, Benji?
Wirklich daheim fühlen sie sich aber
trotzdem nicht.
Im Moment ist es ein Auf und Ab.
Manchmal ist es nicht so einfach.
Es gab auch Zeiten,
in denen wir uns gut fühlten.
Doch dann ...
Im Moment
fühle ich mich nicht wirklich,
als wäre ich hier angekommen.
Das ist schon so.
Manchmal hat man doch wieder
etwas Sehnsucht nach der Schweiz.
Ja, das ist schon so.
Voller Vorfreude
verliessen die Waldburgers
einst ihre Heimat im Thurgau,
um hier ein Hundehotel zu bauen.
Doch die spanische Bürokratie
und nicht zuletzt Corona
stellten sie immer wieder vor
Probleme. Alles verzögerte sich.
Wir haben jetzt die Baubewilligung
der Stadt erhalten -
mit noch mehr Auflagen
als wir bisher schon hatten.
Wir müssen jetzt ein Haus bauen,
das in die Landschaft passt.
Da mussten wir sagen,
dass wir das nicht wollen.
Wir hatten auch noch
keine Eröffnungslizenz für den Bau,
den wir jetzt geplant hatten.
Es hätte sein können,
dass wir gebaut hätten,
und schlussendlich doch keine
Eröffnungslizenz erhalten hätten.
Dann hätten wir einen Bau
von über 100'000 Euro
den wir gar nicht
hätten nutzen können.
Das wollten wir nicht.
Das Projekt mit dem Hundehotel
ist gestorben.
Nun müssen sich die Waldburgers
neu orientieren.
Schauen wir mit den beiden
noch einmal zurück auf die Zeit,
als sie ihr geregeltes Leben
in der Schweiz hinter sich liessen.
Sommer 2019.
In einer Autowerkstatt in Egnach hegt
Ralf Waldburger neue Zukunftspläne.
(Ton aus dem Laptop)
Kurz vor seinem 50. Geburtstag
will er sein Leben
nochmals komplett neu ausrichten.
Seit neun Jahren
ist der gelernte Autolackierer
Chef des Ersatzteillagers.
Nun hat er
seinen sicheren Job gekündigt.
Heute ist sein letzter Arbeitstag.
Zu Hause in Steinebrunn
im Kanton Thurgau
bereitet Ehefrau Corinne
Muffins für Ralfs Abschiedsfest vor.
Seit einem Jahr
ist Corinne mit Ralf verheiratet.
Die beiden haben sich
auf einer Dating-Plattform
im Internet kennengelernt.
Es war Corinne, die Ralf zum
Abenteuer Auswanderung inspirierte.
Als Ralf das erste Mal
mit mir nach Spanien kam,
hat er sich eigentlich
sofort verliebt - in Spanien.
Und dann haben wir gesagt:
Wir versuchen es.
Daraufhin hörten wir uns
in Spanien etwas um,
was dort gefragt ist,
was wir unternehmen könnten.
Als der Vorschlag
mit den Hunden kam,
war ich sofort Feuer und Flamme.
Das ist etwas,
was ich schon immer tun wollte.
Das ist eigentlich mein Baby,
die Sache mit den Hunden, ja.
Ein Hotel ausschliesslich für Hunde
wollen die Waldburgers bauen.
Für Hunde, deren Besitzer ohne
ihre Vierbeiner verreisen wollen.
Warst du zu Hause?
Ralfs Sohn Mischa hilft seinem Vater,
das Fest herzurichten.
Mischa verlor seine Mutter, Ralfs
erste Frau, vor drei Jahren an Krebs.
Umso enger ist die Bindung
zu seinem Vater.
Für mich ändert sich vieles.
Ich muss meine erste Wohnung suchen.
Ich werde allein sein.
Mal schauen, wie das sein wird.
Die Grosseltern, Patentante
und Kollegen sind noch da.
Mal schauen, wie es wird,
wenn Vater weit weg ist,
und ich ihn
nur ein paar Mal im Jahr sehe.
Noch einmal Bratwürste
und Appenzeller Bier.
Ta-raa!
Das Dessertbuffet ist eröffnet,
wenn jemand Lust auf Dessert hat.
Es war schön in der Schweiz -
das Wohnen und die Menschen,
die in der Schweiz waren.
Es tut etwas ...
Es wühlt einen ein wenig auf.
Wenn wir sehen, wie das damals war,
kommen die Emotionen wieder hoch.
Wir sind voller Hoffnung
ausgewandert,
um unseren Traum des Hundehotels
zu verwirklichen.
Doch das hat nicht geklappt.
Ich hätte die kurzen Hosen
anziehen können.
Ja, hier schon.
- Mensch.
Ankunft in Spanien im November 2019.
* Corinne jubelt. *
Schau mal, unser Logo!
Unser loco loco!
(Lachend) Sie sitzen schon bereit.
Das Anwesen mit zwei Häusern
haben die beiden
vor wenigen Monaten gekauft.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Corinnes Eltern
sind zur Begrüssung gekommen.
Sie leben schon seit Jahren hier.
Salü.
- (Frau) Bienvenido.
Im Moment
saugen wir einfach alles auf.
Heute Morgen
fuhren wir bei 6 °C los.
Und jetzt stehe ich da und weiss:
Ich bin für immer da.
Das ist einfach der Hammer.
Wir waren voller Tatendrang.
- Wir haben uns darauf gefreut.
Wir waren von unserem Vorhaben
überzeugt.- Ja.
Waldburgers spanisches Paradies
ist über 6'000 m2 gross.
Platz genug für ihre Hundepension
für bis zu zwölf Tiere,
die sie hier bauen wollen.
Noch aber fehlt ihnen
die Baubewilligung,
die ihnen ihr Architekt
vor dem Kauf zugesichert hatte.
Eine Journalistin
von den "Costa Nachrichten"
ist auf die Auswanderer aus
der Ostschweiz aufmerksam geworden.
Möchten Sie einen Kaffee oder so?
Nicht?
Sie will einen Bericht schreiben
über Corinne und Ralf.
Das Hundehotel
besteht aus Elementbauten,
die wir kaufen können.
Dann wird es bunt angemalt.
Die Böden werden mit Linoleum
verlegt.- Linoleum oder Laminat.
Damit es nachher
wirklich wie ein Hotel aussieht.
Hier haben wir dann
die Einfahrt für die Kunden.
Auf diesem Stück
wird dann das Hundehotel gebaut.
Wir fühlten uns gut vorbereitet.
Uns war bewusst,
dass es nicht einfach werden würde,
dass ein Neustart in einem
anderen Land nicht einfach ist.
Aber wir konnten nicht voraussehen,
wie es ausgehen würde.
Komm mal eben. Ich sehe mir
gerade den Akustikplan durch.
Mhm.
Wenige Wochen später erhalten Wald-
burgers Post von ihrem Architekten.
Es ist nicht
die ersehnte Baubewilligung,
sondern
ein 90-seitiges Lärmschutzgutachten.
Das ist alles auf Spanisch.
Ich übersetze es, um zu verstehen,
was das genau heisst.
Nun habe ich gesehen, dass wir
das Hotel gar nicht so bauen können,
wie wir es gerne gebaut hätten.
Wenn wir es
wie geplant bauen würden,
müssten wir um das ganze Gebäude
eine Mauer bauen.
Also etwa 50 m Mauer
im Abstand von 4 m zum Gebäude.
Und die Mauer müsste 3 m hoch sein.
Uns hat sofort verwundert,
dass das Dokument vom 23.8.2019 ist.
D.h., das wurde gemacht,
bevor wir das Haus gekauft hatten.
Hätte man uns dieses Dokument
vorher unterbreitet,
hätten wir das nicht gekauft.
Dann hätten wir
ganz neue Pläne gemacht.
Corinne und Ralf wollen Klarheit
und laden ihren Architekten
zu einem Gespräch ein.
Das Problem ist,
dass wir dieses Dokument bis vor
zwei Wochen noch nie gesehen haben.
Gemäss dieses Plans müssen wir
eine 3 m hohe Mauer bauen.
(Rubén) Mhm. Im Prinzip.
- (Ralf) Im Prinzip.
(Ralf) Nein, das müssen wir.
Das steht so im Gesetz.
Wir müssen das alles
richtig verstehen.
Das ist natürlich etwas kompliziert.
Wir sind in Spanien,
und du bist Schweizer.
Gesetz ist natürlich Gesetz.
Das ist keine Mathematik.
Eine Mauer ist das Einfachste,
das Schnellste, das Billigste.
Das ist eine Lösung.
Das ist nur,
um die Genehmigung zu bekommen.
Ralf und Corinne
scheinen verunsichert.
Wir hatten teilweise das Gefühl,
wir werden hingehalten.
Es hiess, wir bräuchten Geduld,
wir seien Schweizer in Spanien.
Natürlich.
Aber auch in Spanien
ist das möglich.
Wir sind nicht die Ersten
mit einem Projekt,
hier gibt es ganz viele.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass es überall so läuft.
Sonst würden hier
gar keine Häuser stehen.
Trotz der Hindernisse sind
die Waldburgers zuversichtlich.
Denn sie sind nicht
die ersten Schweizer,
die hier ein Hundehotel
betreiben wollen.
Wir machen Tagesausflüge mit den
Hunden, die bei uns beherbergt sind,
und kommen hierher zum Schwimmen.
Perfekt.- Genau.
Ein Tagesausflug.
* Corinne lacht. *
Sag mir, wenn du 20 m hast.
- Warte kurz.
Stopp, stopp, stopp.
Die Bewilligung für den Bau
lässt aber weiter auf sich warten.
Und dann werden auch noch
die Nachbarn zum Problem.
Sie wollen nicht, dass Waldburgers
hier ein Hundehotel eröffnen.
Hier hat er seine Bedenken
geäussert.
Die Lebensqualität
wäre nicht mehr dieselbe wie zuvor.
Verschmutzung, Lärm.
Das ist das Eine.
Ein anderer Nachbar hat Bedenken,
dass sein Land
an Wert verlieren könnte,
wenn ein Hundehotel hier steht.
Sie haben Unterschriften gesammelt.
Das sind mehrere Seiten.
Es ist ein komisches Gefühl, die
Nachbarn schon gegen sich zu haben,
bevor man überhaupt
richtig angekommen ist.
Das ist kein schöner Start.
* Rhythmisches Trommeln,
Gesang und Klatschen *
Schatz, wir müssen reingehen.
- Ah.
Ein Freitagabend im September 2021.
Dianne und Marco Schommer
sind zu einem Apéro eingeladen.
Das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Firmengründerinnen aus Ruanda
sollen sich hier mit Schweizer
Unternehmerinnen vernetzen.
Hallo.
Hello, my dear.
Dianne kennt beide Länder gut.
Nach über 20 Jahren in der Schweiz
sehnte sie sich danach in ihr
Heimatland Ruanda zurückzukehren.
Mit der Unterstützung
ihres Mannes Marco
baute sie in Kigali
einen Fitnessklub.
(Englisch)
Marco war offen
für die Träume seiner Frau.
Dafür verliess er Freunde
und Verwandte in der Schweiz.
In Ruanda startete er ohne Job,
aber mit der Gewissheit,
dass seine Fähigkeiten und Talente
auch hier gefragt sein würden.
Ich bin happy, dass ich
diesen Schritt gemacht habe.
Als ich im Flugzeug sass,
wurde ich gefragt:
"Wie ist das für dich?"
"Gehst du zurück nach Ruanda
oder gehst du nach Hause?"
Ich antwortete:
"Ich gehe nach Hause."
Ich bin nur noch
mit der Schweiz verbunden
durch meinen Sohn und meine Familie.
Ich muss vieles lernen,
aber es ist gut.
Ich bin glücklich, ja.
Sogar die Covid-Situation
wird es jetzt langsam besser.
Es kann nur noch besser werden.
Marco und Dianne scheinen
in Ruanda angekommen zu sein.
Nun leben sie in einer
ganz anderen Welt als jener,
die sie mit ihrer Auswanderung
zurückgelassen haben.
Im solothurnischen Bettlach.
Für Dianne Schommer sind gemeinsame
Essen mit der Familie wichtig.
Jetzt erst recht,
denn schon bald verlassen sie und ihr
Ehemann die Schweiz - für immer.
Als Dianne in den 90er-Jahren aus
ihrer Heimat Ruanda flüchten musste,
war die Schweiz ihr Zufluchtsort.
Sie integrierte sich schnell.
Bei einem Treffen mit Freunden lernte
sie ihren späteren Mann Marco kennen.
Eine Woche später
waren wir zusammen.
Das ist jetzt 22 Jahre her.
Jetzt nehme ich ihn mit nach Afrika.
Ja.
Inzwischen sind es 24 Jahre.
Am Neuenburgersee in einer
internationalen Uhrmacherschule:
Hier arbeitet der Afrikaauswanderer
Marco Schommer, Diannes Ehemann.
Can we come quick?
- (Mann) Yeah, yeah.
Heute beginnen Schüler
ihre zweijährige Ausbildung.
Good luck this afternoon
when starting filing.
Okay. See you. Bye-bye.
Seit dem Abschluss
seines Ingenieurstudiums
arbeitet Marco in der Uhrenindustrie.
Die Schule leitet er übergangsweise.
Seine vorherige,
langjährige Anstellung
verlor er
nach einer Umstrukturierung.
In Ruanda muss er sich nun
eine neue Aufgabe suchen.
Auswandern ist ein Risiko.
Man verlässt das gewohnte Leben
und beginnt etwas Neues.
Das ist halt ein wenig ...
Das kann gut gehen oder eben nicht.
Voilà.
Marco.
- Give me five.
Hi, Dylan.
- Hi, Mum.
How are you?
- I'm fine.
Zum Abendessen
kommt Sohn Dylan zu Besuch.
Der 22-Jährige ist semi-
professioneller Basketballspieler.
Er wird in der Schweiz bleiben.
You will miss my kitchen.
- Mhm.
Yeah.
I've already been missing it.
Mir war damals noch nicht klar,
was uns erwarten würde.
Ich hatte noch keinen Job.
Die Angst, nicht durchzukommen,
war sicher da.
Aber wirklich dort zu leben, sich
wirklich durchschlagen zu müssen,
ein Haus zu finden usw.
haben wir uns da
noch gar nicht richtig vorgestellt.
Kigali, die Hauptstadt Ruandas.
Im Herbst 2019 kommt Marco Schommer
in seiner neuen Heimat an.
Welcome.
Marcos Frau Dianne ist vorausgereist,
um alles vorzubereiten.
Hey!
- Sali!
* Beide lachen glücklich. *
Was Marco nicht weiss: Dianne hat ein
Begrüssungsfest für ihn organisiert.
Welcome home, Schätzchen.
Danke.
Hello! Hey! Oh, my god.
* Jubel, Applaus *
Wow!
Wow.
Hello!
Hey, Annette.
Die ganze Familie war da.
Hei ei ei.
(Englisch)
Endlich.
* Alle lachen. *
* Sanfte afrikanische Musik *
Einen schöneren Empfang hätte sich
Marco kaum vorstellen können.
Habe ich da so schlimm getanzt?
- Mhm.
Oh Gott.
Einige Wochen später.
Nach langer Suche
hat Dianne passende Räumlichkeiten
für ihr Fitnessstudio gefunden.
Sie befinden sich dort,
wo man sie nicht vermutet:
im hinteren Teil einer Bar.
* Hämmern *
Es klingt ja schon mal gut.
D.h., sie arbeiten. Oh, là, là!
Nun wird alles komplett umgebaut,
ganz nach den Bedürfnissen
der Schommers.
Mwaramutse.
Die Arbeiter müssen Wände versetzen,
die Decke neu machen
sowie Duschen und Toiletten einbauen.
Schau mal, wie das aussieht.
Heiliger Bimbam.
1'000 ¤ kosten die Räume im Monat.
Ich freue mich, wenn es fertig ist.
Jetzt weiss ich nicht,
wo ich hinsehen soll.
Ah, bonjour, bonjour.
- Hallo.
Vermieter Hamlet
kümmert sich um den Umbau.
Die Schommers haben ihm dafür
vier Monatsmieten im Voraus bezahlt.
Auch den Zugang zum Studio
wird Hamlet neu machen.
Dazu muss er mehrere Wände
durchbrechen, bis hin zur Strasse.
(Französisch)
Vermieter Hamlet ist zuversichtlich,
dass er aus dieser Halle in wenigen
Wochen ein Fitnessstudio machen kann.
* Möwenschreie, Meeresrauschen *
Mirabelle und Alain Caboussats Leben
ist eine Baustelle,
seit sie vor drei Jahren
mit ihren beiden Söhnen
vom Emmental nach Norddeutschland
ausgewandert sind.
Mein Liftboy.
Du bekommst noch Trinkgeld.
- Genau.
Die beiden erwarben in Cuxhaven
einen stillgelegten Wasserturm.
Ihr kühner Plan:
ein Café 40 m hoch über der Stadt.
Dazu ein Bed and Breakfast
und Gewerberäume.
Hier sieht man die Risse.
Dafür müssen sie den denkmal-
geschützten Turm komplett umbauen.
Doch alles dauert viel länger
als gedacht.
Nach jahrelanger Planung
konnten sie jetzt zumindest mit
der Sanierung der Fassade beginnen.
Aber immer wieder
entdecken sie neue Probleme.
Die Metallbänder unterhalb
des Turmkopfes sind stark verrostet.
Das sieht nicht gut aus.
Noch ist unklar, ob die Schäden
die Statik des Turmes beeinflussen.
Der ist auch nicht mehr gut.
Verdammt nochmal.
Wir haben das Problem, bzw.
stehen wir vor der Herausforderung,
dass wir hier eine Lösung brauchen.
Mit den Drohnen
haben das nicht gesehen.
Jetzt haben wir das Gerüst
und wollen es richtig machen.
Das geht sehr schnell ins Geld.
Das belastet uns schon.
Es ist wie auf einer Achterbahn.
Gleich müssen wir anhalten,
sonst fahren wir oben raus.
So.
Hier oben hat man die schönste
Aussicht. Es gibt nichts Schöneres.
Auf dem Kamin, der noch höher ist,
ist sie noch besser.
Alles dreht sich bei Familie
Caboussat um den Wasserturm -
seit bald vier Jahren.
Als wir hierhergekommen sind
für einen Termin mit dem Notar,
war es sehr stürmisch.
Wir hatten schon damals
einen Hindernislauf.
Das wäre womöglich
ein Vorzeichen gewesen ...
Nehmt ihn nicht.
Das Unwetter bei
der Schlüsselübergabe für den Turm
war nur ein Vorgeschmack auf das,
was noch folgen würde.
Wie viele Hürden
die Caboussats bewältigen mussten,
hätten sie sich
niemals träumen lassen.
Lokaltermin mit den Architekten
im Frühjahr 2018.
Mirabelle und Alain
stellen ihre Pläne vor.
... mit den Fenstern und
das Treppenhaus war eine Pflicht.
Die Räume sind so hoch,
wie ich es erwartet habe - über 4 m.
Die Idee ist,
dass hier ein Gewerbe einzieht.
Sei das eine Boutique
oder eine Weinhandlung -
einfach etwas Spezielles wäre schön.
In den darüber liegenden Stockwerken
wollen wir ein Bed and Breakfast
mit je zwei Zimmern einrichten.
Im dritten Stock wollen wir
eine Ferienwohnung einrichten.
Dort oben wollen wir
auch das Café einrichten
und vielleicht, wenn es geht,
noch eine Wohnung.
Bevor Mirabelle und Alain
den Turm kauften,
liessen sie Gutachten erstellen.
Wir liessen alles
von Experten abklären.
Sie haben uns versichert,
dass alles möglich sei.
Wir haben auch eine Zusammenstellung
der Kosten erhalten
und hatten noch etwas draufgelegt.
Das sah alles gut aus,
die Bank war einverstanden.
Die Planung und unsere Vorstellungen
waren eigentlich gut.
Unter dem Dach: das Herzstück.
Das ist der Wassertank.
Die Seiten sind ... 12 m hoch?
12 m.
- Sie sind von hier aus 12 m hoch.
Gross wie ein Einfamilienhaus
ist der Tank.
Sein Fassungsvermögen:
knapp 1 Mio. l Wasser.
Es wäre witzig, wenn man hier
ein Café hineinbauen könnte,
sodass man die Wände sieht.
Das ist ...
Das ist wirklich
ein schweres Millionenprojekt.
Wir müssen schauen,
was für die Zukunft sinnvoll ist.
Ein Café im Turm,
40 m hoch über der Stadt.
Vier Monate später
ist es dann soweit.
In Langnau im Emmental
packen die Caboussats ihre Sachen.
Ihr Einfamilienhaus
haben sie verkauft.
Ein voller Laster,
das ist die ganze Habe,
die sie mit ins neue Leben
an die Nordsee nehmen.
(Ton aus dem Laptop) Ist es besser,
erst diese Kisten
oder erst die Möbel rauszutragen?
Oha! Yannis -
Achtung, Schwertransport.
Yannis soll in der neuen Heimat
die obligatorische Schulzeit beenden.
Sein älterer Bruder Nicolas wird sich
in Cuxhaven eine Lehrstelle suchen.
Ich konnte mich darauf einstellen,
dass wir wegziehen.
Das weiss ich ja schon länger.
Deshalb bin ich nicht fassungslos,
dass wir jetzt gehen.
Nein, es ist wirklich ...
Vom Kanton Bern an den äussersten
Zipfel Deutschlands, ans Wattenmeer.
Fischerei und Tourismus
prägen Cuxhaven.
Hier befindet sich
die neue Wohnung der Familie.
Vier Zimmer, knapp 100 m2.
Ein Neuanfang - auch für ihre Kinder.
Ich war etwas angespannt.
Man will ja nur das Beste.
Aber für sie
ist es doch ein grosser Schritt.
Ich habe schon gehofft,
dass alles gut klappt.
Ich vermisse die Heimat schon.
Allgemein die Natur.
Hier gibt es auch Natur,
aber es ist nicht dasselbe.
Die Berge und allgemein -
das vermisse ich.
Ich möchte gerne zurückgehen.
Ob ins Emmental - mal schauen,
aber ich denke schon.
Der Wasserturm prägt von Anfang an
das neue Leben der Caboussats.
Noch planen die Architekten,
aber schon bald
wollen sie das Baugesuch einreichen.
Per Mail hat Mirabelle ein Angebot
für den Einbau eines Liftes bekommen.
Es sind Leute gekommen,
die sich angesehen haben,
wie es zu machen ist.
Es sind auch Brandschutzsachen
zum Vorschein gekommen,
die wieder Fragen aufgeworfen haben.
Es ist manchmal ziemlich aufwendig,
zum Ziel zu kommen.
Ein paar Hundert Meter weiter hat
sich Alain ein Atelier angemietet.
Bis der Gästebetrieb im Wasserturm
läuft, ist die Familie
auf den Verdienst aus seinem
alten Job als Messeleiter angewiesen.
Ich habe noch
für zwei bis drei Monate ein Mandat.
Ich schaue gerade,
welche neuen Aufgaben
ich im Messebereich
als Freelancer übernehmen kann.
Jetzt muss man halt
mit den Leuten schauen,
das Beziehungsnetz spielen lassen.
Hallo, Ivan. Wie geht es dir?
In einem Strandhotel
absolviert Nicolas, der ältere Sohn,
unterdessen sein erstes Praktikum.
Wunderschönen guten Morgen zusammen.
- (Alle) Guten Morgen.
Herr Caboussat geht gleich
mit Frau Loth nach oben,
in die sechste Etage.
Alle zusammen!
(Alle) Eins, zwei, drei,
keep the house clean.
Schon bald wird Nicolas eine Lehre
zum Hotelfachmann beginnen.
Sein jüngerer Bruder Yannis
jobbt neben der Schule
als Zeitungsausträger
und bessert so sein Taschengeld auf.
Ich habe schnell Freunde gefunden.
Mit denen
habe ich auch schon gegamet.
Man trifft sich weniger, sondern
spielt eher online miteinander.
Ich bin zufrieden mit dem,
was ich jetzt habe.
Die Caboussats leben sich schnell
an der Nordsee ein.
Nehmen wir den raus. Nico, du kannst
auf der anderen Seite ziehen.
Die Monate ziehen ins Land, aber die
Planung bei den Caboussats stockt.
Wegen des Cafés im Wassertank
sind noch immer viele Fragen offen.
V.a. beim Brandschutz.
Das Problem: Der Turm ist zu hoch
für die Leiter der Feuerwehr.
Wir warten seit ca. vier Monaten
auf den Bericht zum Brandschutz.
Denn dieses Gebäude ist
brandschutztechnisch sehr komplex.
Wir wollen nur ein Treppenhaus
behalten, das ist unser Ding.
Darum mussten wir
Vor- und Schutzräume machen.
Und auch einen Überdruck
im Treppenhaus,
damit es
keine Rauchentwicklung gibt.
Wir hatten das Gefühl,
dass wir das in zwei Monaten haben -
wenn wir es mal besprochen,
berechnet und angeschaut haben.
Aber jetzt sind wir
schon bei fünf, sechs Monaten.
Und deswegen geht es nicht vorwärts.
Geht es in diesem Tempo weiter,
wird es noch lange dauern,
bis die Caboussats
mit dem Umbau beginnen können.
Eine Wahrsagerin.
Besser läuft es in den ersten Monaten
der Auswanderung bei den Schommers,
trotz beginnender Coronakrise.
Dianne hat einen Termin
beim Schreiner.
Das ist der Step fürs Aerobic.
Wir haben 30 Stück bestellt.
Sie sind noch dran,
es ist noch nicht fertig.
Das hier gefällt mir z.B. nicht,
hier hat es einen Spalt.
* Er spricht Kinyarwanda. *
Er hat gesagt,
dass sie das korrigieren.
Na ja, gut.
Auch auf der Baustelle im
zukünftigen Fitnessklub der Schommers
gibt es Fortschritte.
Ah, das ist die Herrentoilette
mit einem Ding. Das ist okay.
Hier ist die Dusche drin,
das ist jetzt auch besser.
Wir haben jetzt WC und Duschen,
haben aber vergessen,
dass man sich ja auch umziehen muss.
Es ist etwas blöd, weil er
die Arbeiten nun schon gemacht hat.
Dieser Gang hier existierte nicht,
den hat er komplett rausgeschlagen.
Aber andernfalls hätte er es
gleich berücksichtigen können,
jetzt ist es
auf gut Deutsch scheisse.
Immerhin: Die Decke im Kursraum
ist bereits fertig.
Die Schommers werden von Diannes Fit-
nessklub allein nicht leben können.
Sie brauchen mehrere Einnahmequellen.
Neben seiner Jobsuche
treibt Marco daher
eine weitere Geschäftsidee voran.
It's growing, growing.
Very good.
Auf 3,5 ha Land liess Marco
Zitronengrassetzlinge anpflanzen.
Aus dem Gras will er später
Duftöl herstellen lassen.
Umgerechnet 30'000 Fr. hat er
für die jungen Pflanzen investiert.
Ich war am Boden zerstört,
als ich sie sah.
Ich dachte:
"Nein! Die Hälfte ist kaputt."
Es wurden 105'000 Setzlinge gesetzt.
Man kann sich vorstellen:
Da steckt einiges an Geld drin.
This is a good example.
- This one is much better.
Aber, und das sieht man gut:
Es kommt.
Ich habe das mit dem lemongrass
nicht wirklich verstanden.
Als er damit begonnen hat
und ich gesehen habe, wie viel Geld
wir da investieren müssen,
dachte ich sofort, dass das
ein grosser Fehler sein würde.
Du dachtest,
wir hätten zu viel investiert.
Ja, viel zu viel.
Okay.
Es dauert noch mehrere Monate,
bis Marco das erste Mal
Zitronengras ernten können wird.
Sommer an der Costa Blanca: Wer kann,
verbringt seine Tage am Meer.
Doch die Auswanderer aus der Schweiz
sind nicht in Stimmung,
die schönen Seiten ihrer neuen Heimat
zu geniessen.
Noch immer warten sie
auf die Baubewilligung.
Und ohne Hundehotel
fehlt ihnen nicht nur das Einkommen,
sondern auch eine Aufgabe.
Tag für Tag müssen sie sich aufs Neue
selbst beschäftigen.
Bald ein Jahr ist es her, dass Ralf
seinen letzten Arbeitstag hatte.
In einem Autohaus im Thurgau
war der 50-Jährige Chef
über das Ersatzteillager.
In Spanien
erhofft er sich mehr Zeit im Alltag.
Jetzt hat er zu viel davon.
Ehefrau Corinne war Sachbearbeiterin
in einem Industriebetrieb.
Es ist keine einfache Zeit.
Wir sitzen 24 Std. aufeinander.
Früher hatte jeder seinen Job.
Jeder war tagsüber beschäftigt.
Jetzt sitzen wir hier und schauen,
was wir tun können.
Es ist nicht einfach,
wenn man keine Beschäftigung hat
oder nichts machen kann.
Das belastet ihn im Moment sehr.
Ich konnte nicht mehr länger nur
dasitzen und in den Tag hineinleben.
Ich musste irgendetwas tun.
Ich war auch in der Schweiz
schon immer ein Macher.
Ich habe viel organisiert
und unternommen.
Mit der Zeit ist mir
die Decke auf den Kopf gefallen.
Durch ein Gespräch mit einem Freund
kommt Ralf auf die Idee,
Ferienimmobilien zu bewirtschaften.
Er gründet eine Firma:
Waldburger Swiss Homeservice.
Kurz darauf
hat er bereits einen ersten Auftrag.
Wir schalteten ein Inserat
in der "Costa Blanca Nachrichten".
Ein Herr
meldete sich auf das Inserat -
so sind wir
zu diesem Auftrag gekommen.
Potenzielle Kunden gäbe es genug.
Viele Mitteleuropäer
besitzen hier ein Ferienhaus.
Eines davon werden die Waldburgers
nun betreuen dürfen.
Guten Morgen.
- Hallo.
Morgen.
Während Jahren
hat das deutsche Ehepaar Schnieber
diese Liegenschaft betreut.
Altershalber
geben sie das Mandat nun ab.
Gehen wir da lang.
Peter Schnieber erklärt den beiden
ihre künftigen Aufgaben.
Man muss also immer, bevor sie
kommen, sauber machen und abstauben.
Genau.
Sie melden sich meist vorher an.
Die Betten müssen
hergerichtet werden.- Super.
Der Hausbesitzer
hat ein Grundpaket gebucht.
D.h., eine wöchentliche Kontrolle
von Haus und Pool,
Lüften und Pflanzen giessen.
Weitere Arbeiten
kann Ralf zusätzlich verrechnen.
Cool, was?
- Das ist ein schöner Arbeitsplatz.
Aber du musst arbeiten, Schatz.
Wir sind nicht zum Vergnügen hier.
Die Idee war,
das als Ergänzung zu machen,
sobald wir die Bewilligung für
das Hundehotel usw. erhalten hätten.
Aber mittlerweile
ist das unser Hauptprojekt.
In Ruanda
sind die Schommers voller Vorfreude.
* Rufe des Stadionsprechers,
Hip-Hop-Musik *
Sohn Dylan
kommt überraschend nach Kigali.
Dylan ist Doppelbürger
und spielt als Basketballer auch für
die ruandische Nationalmannschaft.
* Jubelschreie *
Dylan!
Oh, baby!
Nach Monaten der Trennung ist Familie
Schommer erstmals wieder vereint.
How do you do?
So viel Zeit ist vergangen. Endlich
sehen wir den Mohungu mal wieder.
Einziger Wehrmutstropfen:
Dylan ist nur kurz hier.
Schon am nächsten Tag
muss er wieder zurück in die Schweiz.
Wenn ich das jetzt so sehe,
bekomme ich etwas Heimweh.
Ja.
Dianne bleibt kaum Zeit für Heimweh
während des Umbaus ihres Studios.
Die Fitnessgeräte werden geliefert.
18 gebrauchte Maschinen
haben die Schweizer
im Hochseecontainer
nach Kigali verschifft.
Sie sind ein Geschenk
von Diannes ehemaligem Arbeitgeber,
bei dem sie als Zumbatrainerin
angestellt war.
Das ist mein Bereich.
Das sind Crosstrainer
und das ist auch wie ein Rad.
In zehn Tagen
soll auch der Kursraum fertig sein.
Ich hoffe,
dass wir am Freitag bereit sind.
Der Raum ist fertig.
Eröffnen kann Dianne
trotzdem noch nicht.
Der Betrieb von Fitnessklubs
ist wegen der Coronakrise
bis auf Weiteres verboten.
* Piepen *
Da wären wir wieder.
Mit jedem Monat Verzögerung
verlieren die Schommers aber Geld.
Umso wichtiger wäre es, dass Marco
in Kigali einen Job findet.
Ich hatte kein gutes Gefühl.
Er hat hier nach einem Job gesucht
und sagte auch,
dass es ihm nicht gut gehen würde.
Langsam habe ich auch
etwas Panik gekriegt.
Aber er hat immer gearbeitet -
keine Ahnung, was.
(Leise) Wunderbar.
Schon vor der Auswanderung hatte
Marco in Ruanda Kontakte geknüpft
und sich nach Jobmöglichkeiten
umgehört.
Dann nach sieben Monaten
hat er ein erstes Mandat.
Im Auftrag einer Stiftung
soll Marco ein Konzept für
die ruandische Regierung erstellen.
Diese möchte
die duale Berufsausbildung
nach Schweizer Modell
in Ruanda einführen.
Das erste Mandat
war ein sehr gutes Gefühl.
Man wird wieder gebraucht.
Ich war zwar immer beschäftigt,
so ist es nicht.
Aber damit konnte ich
auch wieder etwas verdienen.
Weitere Wochen ziehen ins Land.
Mittlerweile
ist der Umbau abgeschlossen
und auch die vergessen gegangenen
Umkleidekabinen sind fertig.
Alles wäre bereit,
aber eröffnen dürfen die Schommers
immer noch nicht.
Dabei sah alles gut aus.
Über Wochen
waren die Corona-Fallzahlen tief.
Die Regierung
kündigte Lockerungen an.
Die Schommers rechneten fest damit,
bald starten zu können.
Doch plötzlich schossen
die Neuinfektionen wieder in die Höhe
und dass Fitnessstudio
muss weiter geschlossen bleiben.
Ich bin so traurig.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie es jetzt weitergeht.
Aber wir putzen jetzt die Maschinen.
Dann möchte ich sie zudecken,
damit sie nicht verstauben.
Ich weisst nicht,
wann es weitergeht.
Wir hatten grosse Freude,
alles war bereit,
dann kam diese Nachricht:
Fertig, Schluss, alles schliessen.
Es geht nicht.
Die Zukunft der Schommers mit ihrem
Fitnessstudio bleibt ungewiss.
Stillstand auch an der Nordsee.
Der Wasserturm in Cuxhaven
wartet weiter darauf,
mit neuem Leben erfüllt zu werden.
Wir müssen vorwärtsmachen
und die Baugenehmigung einreichen.
Nichts geht mehr, auch bei Alain.
Wegen der Coronakrise
wurde seine geplante Messe abgesagt.
Das Problem ist, dass das finanziell
gar nicht mehr möglich ist.
Aber Kunststofffenster
sind ca. 60 Euro günstiger.
203'000 - nein, hör auf.
Das müssen wir runterkriegen.
Und durch zusätzliche Auflagen
der Behörden
wird das Projekt immer teurer.
Auf der Suche nach einer Lösung
haben sie einen Termin mit dem
neuen Oberbürgermeister vereinbart.
Hallo. Guten Morgen.
- Herzlich willkommen.
Hier eine Kleinigkeit aus
der Schweiz für Ihre Kaffeepause.
Danke.
Oberbürgermeister Uwe Santjer
und Baudezernent Martin Adamski
haben eine knappe Stunde Zeit
für die Caboussats und ihr Projekt.
Danke.
- Gerne.
Ich finde es gut,
dass wir uns heute treffen.
Wir sind froh, dass Sie da sind.
Das sind schöne Worte.
- Mhm.
Es bleibt bei den Worten.
Holzfenster kosten über 65'000 Euro
mehr als Kunststofffenster.
Beim Dach muss man
das Geländer innen anschauen.
Es muss vieles gemacht werden.
Aber wir können uns
nicht alles leisten.
Was Sie gesagt haben,
können wir nachvollziehen.
Es gab einen ersten Impuls
der Wirtschaftsförderung.
Das werden wir angehen.
- Bei den Fenstern wird es bleiben.
Aber wir schauen, dass wir es
mit Fördergeldern hinkriegen,
dass die Belastung zumutbar ist.
Wir haben
keine Fördergelder erhalten. Nichts.
Leider haben sie angeblich
keine Gelder in den Töpfen.
Das sagte mir jetzt der
Denkmalschutzbeauftragte wieder.
Sie sagen zwar, sie freuen sich ...
- ... dass wir da sind.
... dass wir das Projekt
durchführen.
Aber wir verstehen etwas anderes
unter Unterstützung.
Aufgeben ist für die Caboussats
aber keine Option. Im Gegenteil.
Bis es mit dem Wasserturm weitergeht,
verfolgen sie eine weitere
Geschäftsidee: ein rollendes Café.
Bitte schön, Mirabelle.
In den Citroen HY,
ein Oldtimer aus Frankreich,
lassen sie eine vollausgestattete
Kaffeeküche einbauen.
Ja, sie haben gearbeitet.
Die Elektrik wurde gemacht.
Wie gefällt dir der Boden?
- Gut.
Das ist gut.
- Tipptopp.
Ich kann sogar stehen.
- Ja.
Du wärst ungefähr dort.
- Etwa hier.
Noch etwas weiter zu mir.
- So.
Und die Kaffeemühle ist hier.
Mit den Einnahmen aus dem Kaffeemobil
wollen sie vorübergehend
ihren Lebensunterhalt bestreiten.
Schatz, wenn wir das so hintun,
würde der Tresen bis hierhin kommen,
das könnte man abdichten.
Mir gefällt es nicht.
Ich sage es ganz klar.
Das ist eine Holzimitation.
Das andere ist auch Holz.
Das passt nicht zusammen.
Das andere ist eine Platte,
die zugeschnitten werden muss.
Dann haben wir eine einzige Fläche.
Das wird mit einer Fuge abgedichtet.
Einen Cappuccino, bitte.
Ideengeber ist grösstenteils
wirklich Alain.
Ich gebe dann noch meinen Senf dazu.
Aber immer so,
dass es für beide stimmt.
So konnten wir bisher alles
so umsetzten, wie wir es wollten.
Das Kaffeemobil wird genau so, wie es
sich die beiden vorgestellt haben.
Aber beim Wasserturm entwickeln sich
die Dinge anders als gewünscht.
Über drei Jahre lang
versuchen die Caboussats alles,
um ihre Vision umzusetzen.
Dann schliesslich treffen sie
eine tiefgreifende Entscheidung.
Sie werden ihr Projekt
radikal verkleinern.
Hast du die Baubeschreibung
gefunden?
Alain und Mirabelle
geben ihre ursprünglichen Pläne auf:
Es wird kein Café im Wassertank oben
geben, 40 m hoch über der Stadt.
Die Richtlinien und
Brandschutzauflagen für Hochhäuser
wurden zu viele und zu aufwendig.
Deshalb mussten wir
eine andere Lösung finden.
Das bedeutet,
dass wir das Café unten haben.
Im ersten Obergeschoss
ist die erste Ferienwohnung,
im zweiten Obergeschoss die zweite
und die dritte Ferienwohnung
ist unterhalb des Technikbereichs.
Ich sehe das nicht als Scheitern.
Man will etwas umsetzen
und macht alles dafür.
Wenn es nicht funktioniert,
es zu teuer wird
oder sonst etwas passiert,
dann ist es halt so.
Durch die Verlegung des Cafés
nach unten ins Erdgeschoss
ist ein Grossteil
der Brandschutzauflagen hinfällig.
Schon bald werden sie das
redimensionierte Gesuch einreichen.
Wir haben am 27. Juli 2021
die Baubewilligung erhalten.
Und wir haben das
nicht mal gefeiert.
Wir hatten so viel zu tun.
Irgendwie haben wir es
gar nicht richtig wahrgenommen.
Wir haben uns schon gefreut.
- Ja.
Aber die Bank teilte uns mit,
die Baustoffe steigen um 30 %,
wir bräuchten
eine neue Finanzierung.
so kam bereits die nächste Hürde.
Drei Projekte, drei Länder,
drei Neuanfänge.
Ohne die Liebe zueinander
hätten es die Auswanderer
nicht bis hierher geschafft.
Wie geht es ihnen heute?
* Hupen *
Herbst 2021:
In Ruanda haben die Menschen nach
einer dritten Corona-Infektionswelle
wieder mehr Freiheiten.
Das sind gute Neuigkeiten
für Dianne Schommer.
Endlich
kann sie ihr Fitnessstudio eröffnen.
Morgen veranstalte ich
die grosse Eröffnung des Gyms.
Jetzt kaufe ich ein für diesen
Anlass, für die Party morgen.
Fast ein Jahr lang musste Dianne
ihr fertiggebautes Studio
wegen Corona geschlossen halten.
Jetzt hat das Warten ein Ende
und Dianne kann ihren Traum
vom eigenen Fitnessklub umsetzen.
Ich bin ein bisschen nervös,
aber ich freue mich auch.
Ich habe ein gutes Gefühl.
Ich denke, es kommen viele Leute.
Auf dem Feld der Schommers
schneiden Arbeiterinnen Zitronengras.
Bis zu viermal pro Jahr
können sie das Gras ernten.
Persönlich aufs Feld fahren
muss Marco dafür nicht mehr.
Wir haben uns so organisiert,
dass wir per Telefon
die Ernte machen können.
Aber wir müssen trotzdem
bald mal wieder vorbeischauen,
um zu düngen,
bevor der grosse Regen kommt.
Aber ich bin nicht mehr oft
fürs lemongrass unterwegs.
So.
Der 53-Jährige hat einen Termin
in der Destillerie vereinbart,
die sein Zitronengras verarbeitet.
(Englisch)
Okay.
Mhm.
It smells already gut,
es riecht schon gut.
Mein Investment
ist wohl noch nicht ...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Es gibt noch nicht so viel her.
Aber ich denke,
es ist eine gute Sache.
Es gibt Community-Jobs,
die Menschen haben etwas zu tun.
Wenn wir Gas geben mit dem Düngen,
wird es sicher besser.
Bis zu 50 l Öl lassen sich
aus einer Ernte herstellen.
Wow.
Auch wenn es sich bisher
noch nicht rechnet -
Marco möchte die Idee vom
Zusatzverdienst mit dem Zitronengras
noch nicht aufgeben.
In Cuxhaven müssen die Gerüstbauer
eine schwierige Aufgabe lösen.
Caboussats wollen den Wassertank
von innen reinigen lassen,
solange der Montagelift steht.
Dazu müssen die Handwerker
ein Hängegerüst
von oben in den Tank einbauen.
* Stimmengewirr *
Hast du die Milch vorbereitet
für den Cappuccino?- Ich bin dabei.
Ein paar Hundert Meter weiter
arbeiten Alain und Mirabelle
in ihrem Kaffeemobil.
Ein Fachgeschäft für Hörakustik
feiert Jubiläum
und hat sie für dieses Event gebucht.
Den Cappuccino mit Milch.
Willst du Milch und Zucker?
Seit einem Jahr sind sie
mit ihrem umgebauten Oldtimer
dreimal pro Woche in der
Cuxhavener Innenstadt anzutreffen.
Kaffee zu verkaufen ist momentan
ihre einzige Einnahmequelle.
Es ist schön, wenn es so gut läuft.
Aber Alain
war auch schon am Hafen und ...
Oje.
Wenn dann auch noch
das Wetter schlecht ist,
steht man ganz alleine da.
Und für die paar Euro -
das rentiert manchmal nicht.
Wenn man pro Stunde
einen halben Kunden hat,
dann ist es ganz schlimm.
Aber wir wollen lieber präsent sein,
als gar nicht.
Längst hätten sie ihre Kunden
im Café im Turm bedienen wollen.
Dass es sich so entwickelt,
hätten wir nie gedacht.
Aber es ist gut so.
Es stimmt für uns in diesem Rahmen.
Aber wir sind froh,
wenn wir bald eröffnen können.
(Frau) Sie haben
mit dem Wasserturm zu tun, oder?
Genau.
- Dann habe ich Sie richtig erkannt.
Ich gebe Ihnen unsere Karte.
- Ich habe das gelesen.
Wir haben auch eine Webseite. Wir
hoffen, nächstes Jahr zu eröffnen.
Nächstes Jahr?
- Ja, das muss sein.
Das hat schon lange gedauert.
Ja. Sonst ist der Spassfaktor
irgendwann zu Ende.
Am 6. Juli muss es fertig sein.
Dann ist es genau 125 Jahre her,
seit er eröffnet wurde.
Wir müssen im Juni fertig sein,
um noch die Einladungen
verschicken zu können.
Aber das gelingt sicher.
Willst du einen Kaffee
oder Cappuccino?
Mach mir einen schönen Cappuccino.
- Gerne.
Der Kaffee der Caboussats
kommt bei den Cuxhavenern an.
Mittlerweile
haben sie schon viele Stammkunden.
Hast du gesehen, was wir
im Zwischenboden gefunden haben?
Ich habe
ganz viele Zeitungen gefunden.
Aus der Zeit, ja?
1931, 1933, 1954, 1975,
80er- und 90er-Jahre.
Ich war ganz stolz.
Vielen Dank. Ich wünsch' dir was.
- Das wünsch' ich dir auch.
(Beide) Tschüss.
Die müssen wir reinziehen.
Trotz treuer Kunden:
Mit den Einnahmen aus dem Kaffeemobil
können sie
gerade so ihre Fixkosten decken.
Wir hatten viel Kaffee.
Insgesamt etwa 110 oder 120.
Umso wichtiger ist es für sie,
dass ihr Turm
so schnell wie möglich fertig wird.
Bis später, Schatz.
- Ja, tschüss.
7 Uhr in der Früh in Spanien.
Okay, dann gehe ich los.
Bis später.
- Ja.
Für Ralf Waldburger beginnt
die Arbeit für seinen Homeservice.
Sechs verschiedene Swimmingpools
muss er heute reinigen.
Im Moment sind alle Pools
noch etwas verstreut.
Deshalb sind die Fahrtwege
etwas länger.
Aber wenn man
ein neues Geschäft aufbaut
muss man zu Beginn nehmen, was man
bekommt, und dann weiterschauen.
Deshalb müssen wir morgens
ziemlich früh raus.
Auch wegen der Wärme.
V.a. im Sommer
wird es sonst tagsüber sehr warm.
In dieser Hitze wird das Arbeiten
dann ziemlich schwierig.
Der 51-Jährige
hat harte Monate hinter sich.
Den Traum vom Hundehotel zu begraben,
fiel ihm schwer.
Zudem klappte der Einstieg
ins neue Business nicht wie erhofft.
Trotz Inseraten und neuer Webseite
meldeten sich kaum Interessenten
für seinen Hausmeisterdienst.
Es ist nicht richtig angelaufen.
Ich hatte auch Probleme,
das Ganze zu akzeptieren.
Ich habe das Problem
immer bei mir gesucht.
Was mache ich falsch?
Das hat mich extrem heruntergezogen.
Wir waren dann soweit,
das Ganze hier unten abzubrechen.
Ralf hatte bereits
ein Jobangebot in der Schweiz.
Doch mit Beginn der neuen Saison
kam die Wende.
Die Waldburgers
erhielten immer mehr Anfragen
und das Geschäft
mit dem Homeservice nahm Fahrt auf.
Das ist eigentlich nicht normal.
Es kann nicht sein, dass das
innerhalb einer Woche so weiss wird.
Ich vermute,
dass der pH-Wert viel zu hoch ist.
Das Wissen über die Poolpflege
hat sich der gelernte Autolackierer
selbst angeeignet.
Der pH-Wert müsste bei dieser Farbe
bei 7,2 liegen.
Wir sind sehr viel drüber.
* Eine Frau spricht Spanisch
über einen Lautsprecher. *
Allen Startschwierigkeiten zum Trotz:
Die Waldburgers
wollen an der Costa Blanca bleiben.
Um es im Alltag
zukünftig leichter zu haben,
will Corinne ihr Spanisch verbessern.
Ich spreche einfach.
Ich quatsche einfach.
Aber ich möchte auch
korrekt sprechen können,
die korrekten Formen verwenden.
Jetzt spreche ich mit den Menschen
einfach drauflos.
Gracias.
Gracias. Ciao ciao, Sabine.
- Ciao ciao. Adiós.
Hola.
Ralf ist in ein Aquacenter gefahren.
Er möchte das Wasser aus dem Pool
analysieren lassen.
Hola. Buenos Días. Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Wie geht's?
- Gut.
Haben Sie auch ein paar Fotos
vom Pool, wie das Wasser aussieht?
Ja, ein Foto
habe ich beim Reinigen gemacht.
Die spanische Angestellte
kennt Ralf bereits gut.
Es ist
nicht ausreichend desinfiziert.
Wahrscheinlich produziert die
Salzelektrolyse-Anlage nicht genug.
Okay.
So ist es für mich viel einfacher,
mein Problem zu erklären.
Mein Spanisch
ist noch nicht so sattelfest,
dass ich auf Spanisch
kommunizieren könnte.
Die Waldburgers
haben sich ein Netzwerk
von deutschsprachigen Kontakten
aufgebaut.
Das ist zwar gut fürs Geschäft,
aber weniger gut für die Integration.
Im ruandischen Kigali ist es soweit.
Was soll ich alles herausnehmen?
Zuerst diese Tasche.
Heute eröffnen die Schommers
ihren Fitnessklub.
* Kirchenglocken *
Die Freude scheint jedoch verhalten.
Schon einmal
hatte ihnen das Coronavirus
einen Strich durch die Rechnung
gemacht.
Endlich geht es richtig los.
Ich bin davon überzeugt,
dass das eine gute Sache wird.
Ob die Eröffnung
der einzige Faktor ist,
der etwas bringt,
weiss ich noch nicht.
Aber sie wird sicher
einen Boost geben.
Ich erwarte, dass Leute kommen.
Und dass sie eine membership kaufen.
Die Auflagen für den Betrieb
des Fitnessklubs sind streng.
Ohne Zertifikat
darf niemand zum Training kommen.
Das ist schlecht für das Geschäft,
denn nicht alle
können sich einen Test leisten.
Zum Eröffnungsfest hat Dianne
Freunde und Bekannte eingeladen
sowie Flyer verteilt.
Hm?
Alles ist bereit. Fast alles.
Haben wir keinen Strom?
Vorhin hatte es Ton.
Nein.
Der hier ist schief.
Hallo, hallo.
* Sie spricht Kinjaruanda. *
(Englisch)
* Beschwingte Musik *
Der Anfang ist gemacht:
Der Fitnessklub ist eröffnet.
Gut 50 Sportbegeisterte
sind zum Fest gekommen.
Mein Traum
ist jetzt in Erfüllung gegangen.
Mein Fitness ist jetzt eröffnet.
Und ich bin sehr glücklich.
* Treibende Musik *
Let's go, let's go!
Hey!
Das erste Training läuft.
Ab jetzt muss Dianne
mit ihrem Fitnessklub Geld verdienen.
An der Costa Blanca
haben die Waldburgers
Freunde und Corinnes Eltern
zum Fussballabend eingeladen.
* Corinne lacht. *
Heute spielt
die Schweizer Nationalmannschaft.
Doch nicht nur beim Fussball
verspürt Ralf immer noch starke
Gefühle für seine alte Heimat.
Hier kannst du ihn einstecken.
- Ja.- Gut.
Im Thurgau konnte er sich
spontan mit seiner Familie treffen.
Hier in Spanien ist das
nicht mehr so einfach möglich.
Ich war es gewohnt,
weil meine Eltern schon
über 15 Jahre in Spanien leben.
Für Ralf ist es schwieriger,
weil er Sehnsucht nach seinem Sohn
und seinen Eltern hat.
Das ist für ihn
nicht ganz so einfach.
Schatz?
- Si?
Soll ich die Teller rausbringen?
- Ja, gerne.
Kommen die Apéro-Teller
auf den Tisch?
Ja,
die würde ich auf den Tisch stellen.
Und die grossen auf den anderen ...
- Auf den grossen Tisch.
Ja.
- Okay.
* Bellen *
Hallo, ihr zwei. Hallo, Schätzchen.
Hola! Hallo.
- Willkommen.- Wie geht's?
Ihre Gäste sind alle Schweizer.
Sie bringen ein Stück Heimat
ins ferne Spanien.
Und für einmal das Gefühl,
wie es hätte sein können,
wenn sich ihr Traum vom Hundehotel
erfüllt hätte.
Jetzt sehen wir, wie es wäre,
wenn es klappen würde.
Wenn wir etwas Leben
hier draussen auf dem campo hätten.
Salud!
* Stimmengewirr *
Salud.
Schweizer Geselligkeit
und spanisches Essen -
an diesem Abend verbinden sich für
die Waldburgers die beiden Welten.
* Applaus und Pfiffe im Fernsehen *
4.30 Uhr in der Früh in Cuxhaven.
Yannis,
der jüngere Sohn der Caboussats,
ist bereits bei der Arbeit.
Seit ein paar Wochen macht er
eine Ausbildung zum Konditor.
Ich stehe um 3 Uhr auf,
die anderen um 2 Uhr.
Sobald ich 18 bin,
werde ich auch um 2 Uhr aufstehen.
Um 3 Uhr beginnt die Arbeit.
Dazu kommt noch die Fahrt
mit dem Fahrrad hierher.
Das Ganze ist gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Klappt alles?
- Ja, alles gut.
Yannis
fühlt sich in Norddeutschland wohl.
Aber nach seiner Ausbildung
möchte er eigene Wege gehen.
Ich wollte schon immer
nach Amerika gehen.
Seit wir in den Ferien
nach Amerika gefahren sind,
bin ich fast etwas verliebt
in Amerika.
V.a. in die Ortschaften.
Die Politik ist nicht so mein Ding,
aber ansonsten das Land.
Oh, nein! Den darf ich
nicht wegwerfen, ich Dussel.
Den darf ich nicht wegwerfen.
Da steht:
"Geboren am 14. Februar 1874."
Diese Latte
habe ich extra zur Seite gelegt.
Aber gegen Abend sehe ich nichts
mehr. Den muss ich zurücknehmen.
Auch Alain startet früh,
für ihn gibt es kaum Freizeit.
Wenn er nicht mit dem Kaffeemobil
unterwegs ist, arbeitet er im Turm.
Jetzt will er sehen, wie weit
die Gerüstbauer gekommen sind.
Sie sollten ein Hängegerüst
in den Wassertank installieren.
Das hat nicht geklappt
mit dem Gerüst.
Das Problem:
Ohne Hängegerüst können die Arbeiter
den Tank nicht wie geplant reinigen.
Heute ist Freitag.
Am Montag wollten sie beginnen.
* Freiton *
Oliver Süss, hallo.
- Guten Tag.
Ich bin auf dem Kreuz.
Ich sehe ganz viel Gerüst,
aber noch nichts im Tank.
Das Problem ist,
dass wir die Aufgabe
nicht wie angedacht lösen können.
Welche Alternativen
oder Möglichkeiten gibt es noch?
Am sinnvollste wäre,
dass wir unten in den Tank
ein 5 m hohes Gerüst mit
einer waagerechten Ebene einbauen,
auf die wir ein Fahrgerüst
stellen könnten.
Ja. Mit welchen Kosten
müssten wir rechnen?
Ich möchte Ihnen
nicht das Wochenende vermiesen,
aber ich schätze, dass wir
bei ca. 15'000 Euro liegen würden.
Das darf ich Mirabelle
nicht erzählen,
sonst bekommt sie einen Schock.
Wenn wir unten eine Plattform
reinbauen, stellt sich die Frage ...
Man muss ja das Material
wieder die 10 m runterbekommt.
Dann fängt es von vorne an.
Dazu brauchen wir einen Kran.
Das kann man
nicht einfach runterwerfen.
Das Licht, der Strom, alles
muss nach unten gebracht werden.
Fürs Hängegerüst
haben wir mir ca. 3'000 gerechnet.
3'000 sind es so oder so,
jetzt kommen 15'000 hinzu.
Das ist ärgerlich.
Und das ist nur eine Schätzung.
Es könnten auch 17'000 sein.
Na gut, es könnten auch 14'000 sein,
aber diese Wahrscheinlichkeit
ist klein.
Na gut.
Jetzt mache ich etwas anders.
Seit Monaten entkernt Alain den Turm,
fast immer allein.
Für den Umbau
des 125 Jahren alten Gebäudes
brauchen die Caboussats
neben viel Geld
auch einen eisernen Durchhaltewillen.
Ich hatte hier
schon so viele Hindernisse.
Ach.
Deshalb machen wir es erst recht.
Wir machen es auch für uns, weil wir
so viel dafür geopfert haben,
bzw. so viele Entbehrungen
gemacht haben.
Wir nehmen keine Ferien, investieren
alles, was wir haben, hier rein.
Wir könnten schon noch
einen Rückzieher machen.
Die Bank hat uns auch vorgeschlagen,
zu verkaufen.
Jetzt, da wir die Baugenehmigung
haben, könnten wir Gewinn machen.
Das war aber nie unsere Idee.
Das Ziel ist,
das fertig zu machen und
zwei Ferienwohnungen zu verkaufen,
damit wir das
gut finanzieren können.
Durch Verkauf
von zwei der drei Ferienwohnungen
wollen Alain und Mirabelle
die gestiegenen Kosten
beim Ausbau des Turmes ausgleichen.
Für Dianne Schommer
beginnt in Kigali der Alltag
als Chefin ihres Fitnessklubs.
Zweimal täglich fährt sie ins Studio,
um Kurse zu geben
und dort nach dem Rechten zu sehen.
* Hupe *
Good morning everybody.
Good morning, Mariette.
Everything good?- Yeah.
Ehemann Marco ist bereits im Büro.
Yes. Morning, morning.
Yes, I'm ready.
Seit Kurzem hat er eine Festanstel-
lung bei einer Schweizer Stiftung.
Marco berät ruandische Firmengründer.
Er hilft ihnen,
ihr Unternehmen aufzubauen.
Zusammen mit einer Mitarbeiterin geht
es für Marco zu einem Aussentermin.
In seinem neuen Job
kann er sein grosses Know-how
aus 25 Berufsjahren in der Schweiz
weitergeben.
Genau das wollte ich.
Ich habe mir gesagt,
dass ich genau das machen sollte.
* Hupe *
Mensch, die fahren wieder,
als hätten sie keinen Kopf.
Aber es ist anstrengend.
(Lachend) Es ist nicht
einfacher als in der Schweiz.
Als Teamleiter
hat Marco einen 80-%-Vertrag.
Mit diesem Job
habe ich genügend Einkommen,
dass wir gut davon leben können.
Ich könnte Dianne im Fitnesscenter
bei Bedarf "subventionieren".
Es sieht zwar relativ gut aus,
aber man weiss ja nie.
Für ruandische Verhältnisse
verdiene ich eigentlich sehr gut.
Marco fährt raus aus der Stadt
in unwegsames Gelände.
Die beiden sind
mit einem Unternehmer verabredet,
der einen Steinbruch betreibt.
Unternehmer Emanuel
möchte seinen Betrieb erweitern
und sich eigene Maschinen kaufen.
Einen Grossteil der Fahrzeuge
hat er bisher gemietet.
Meine Aufgabe wird sein,
seine finanzielle Situation
anzuschauen und zu analysieren,
zu beurteilen, wie realistisch
seine Vorstellungen sind.
Ich werde ihm Optionen unterbreiten,
zwischen denen er sich dann
entscheiden kann.
Marco braucht noch genauere Zahlen,
um Emanuel beim Ausbau seines Stein-
bruchunternehmens helfen zu können.
An der Costa Blanca
bereiten die Waldburgers
ein Ferienhaus für neue Gäste vor.
Wie ein Ghostbuster, was?
Ralf hat mir
einen Staubsauger gekauft,
den ich mir
auf den Rücken schnallen kann.
Das ist etwas bequemer,
das ist genial.
Man muss sich die Arbeitsgänge
so bequem wie möglich machen.
Jetzt habe ich
einen Rückenstaubsauger.
* Dröhnen *
Corinne und Ralf
kümmern sich mittlerweile
um 17 verschiedene Liegenschaften.
Die Besitzer der Immobilien
leben alle in der Schweiz.
Ferienhäuser reinigen
anstatt Vierbeiner
im eigenen Hundehotel betreuen.
Das ist der neue Alltag
der Auswanderer.
Ich habe mir nicht erträumt,
einmal Häuser zu putzen.
* Sie lacht. *
Aber das machen wir
jetzt mal vorübergehend.
Und ja ...
Wir machen das Beste daraus.
Neu ist auch,
dass Ralf und Corinne die Arbeit
miteinander absprechen müssen.
Bei den Häusern, die wir betreuen,
macht Corinne den Innenbereich
und ich den Aussenbereich.
So haben wir das aufgeteilt.
In der Schweiz gingen sie unter der
Woche jeweils ihrem eigenen Job nach.
In Spanien sind sie nun
fast rund um die Uhr zusammen.
Es ist nicht ganz einfach,
so lange immer beieinander zu sein
und auch zusammen zu arbeiten.
Gemeinsam zu arbeiten
haben wir bisher nicht gekannt.
Zusätzlich zur Belastung, die wir
durch das Hundehotel etc. hatten,
ist das eine weitere
ziemliche Herausforderung.
Aber wir schaffen das,
weil unsere Liebe gross genug ist.
Wir machen das gemeinsam.
Ich gebe noch fossa settica rein.
- Ja.
Wir haben
unterschiedliche Auffassungen,
wie man gewisse Arbeiten
ausführen sollte.
Aber mittlerweile
akzeptieren wir beide:
Sie macht es auf ihre Art
und ich auf meine Art.
Das muss man einfach akzeptieren.
Weiter geht's zum nächsten Auftrag.
Was die beiden zusätzlich belastet:
Bisher verdienen sie mit ihrem
Homeservice nicht genug Geld.
Mit den Aufträgen,
die wir derzeit haben ...
... können wir unseren
Lebensunterhalt nicht finanzieren.
Wir leben im Moment zur Hälfte
von unserem Ersparten, das ist so.
Aber wenn wir ehrlich sind,
hatten wir das
auch mit dem geplanten Hundehotel
für die ersten zwei Jahre
so berechnet,
dass wir auch
vom Ersparten leben müssen.
In den nächsten paar Wochen
und Monaten,
in denen es etwas ruhiger wird,
müssen wir das überdenken.
Wir müssen schauen, was rentiert und
in welche Richtung wir gehen wollen.
Hinzu kommt: Mit der Betreuung
von 17 Liegenschaften
sind sie schon fast ausgelastet.
Wenn man auswandert, muss man
meistens mehr arbeiten als zu Hause.
Man muss viel länger und viel härter
für das Geld arbeiten,
das man am Ende erhält.
Die Löhne hier unten
sind natürlich nicht hoch.
Man hat viel mehr Aufwand,
bis auch etwas zusammenkommt.
Easy life gibt es nicht.
Ein Job, der sie nicht erfüllt,
die Beziehung belastet
und zu wenig einbringt.
Die Waldburgers
müssen sich überlegen,
was ihnen das Leben in Spanien
wert ist.
Beim Wasserturm haben die Caboussats
eine Lösung für das Problem
mit dem Gerüst gefunden.
Und sie ist
einfach und kostengünstig.
Sie liessen ein Loch
in den Metalltank schneiden,
durch das die Arbeiter
ins Innere steigen können.
Das teure Gerüst war damit hinfällig.
Aber kaum haben Mirabelle und Alain
ein Problem bei ihrem Turm gelöst,
scheinen zwei neue aufzutauchen.
Trotz Baubewilligung geht es
immer noch sehr langsam voran.
Architekten, Statiker und Planer
müssen sich
über das weitere Vorgehen einigen.
Dann haben wir
die Decken in der Küche.
(Mann) Das ist genau das Thema,
bei dem ich auch auf die Antwort von
der Bauleitung oder vom Bauherrn.
Soweit ich weiss,
wurde schon lange bestimmt,
dass es ein Trockenaufbau sein wird.
Der Trittschall
muss natürlich gewährleistet sein,
es gibt auch keine Bodenheizung
und es kommt ein Parkett drüber.
Das ist alles.
Ja.
Das ist schon mal eine gute Info.
Es ist tatsächlich
nicht ganz unkompliziert.
Standardlösungen gibt es
für den 48 m hohen Turm nicht.
Jedes Detail
muss neu durchdacht werden.
Fehlt eine Information,
verzögert sich sofort alles.
Mirabelle versucht zu vermitteln.
Letztendendes
sind wir die Bauherren.
Wir sind zwar da, aber wir können
nicht alles durchorganisieren.
Ihr müsst miteinander sprechen,
wenn ihr bestimmte Sachen wollt.
Jetzt beim Architekten nachfragen.
(Entfernt) Es ist wichtig,
dass dieser Austausch stattfindet.
Auch Nicolas,
der für seine Abschlussprüfung
zum Hotelfachmann lernt,
bleiben die Schwierigkeiten seiner
Eltern natürlich nicht verborgen.
Wenn man hört, was alles nicht
klappt, ist das natürlich ärgerlich.
Ich werde in der Schule und
auf der Arbeit immer wieder gefragt:
"Erzähl,
wie es mit dem Wasserturm voran?"
Natürlich
interessieren sich alle dafür.
Ich erzähle schon davon, aber ich
kann auch nicht mehr dazu sagen,
als das, was wir momentan machen.
Das ist manchmal etwas blöd.
Aber es ist halt so.
Ich glaube, es wird schon alles gut.
Irgendwie dreht sich alles
immer wieder um dieselben Themen.
Diese Leute
haben sich alles x-mal angeschaut.
Dann heisst es auf dem Bau,
alles sei kein Problem,
alles sei gut.
Doch sobald man etwas
schriftlich braucht, heisst es:
"Da müssen wir
noch genauer hinschauen."
Dann braucht es noch dies und jenes.
Dann fehlt es teilweise
auch an der Kommunikation.
Alles zieht sich unnötig
stark in die Länge.
Brauchen Sie noch ein Löffelchen?
- Ja.
Hier.
- Danke schön.
Moin, hallo.
Ich nehme eine Käsewurst.
- Ja, gerne.
Und Pommes.
Hallo.
Hi, Brigitte. Hallo.
Positiv bleiben, Rückschläge abhaken
und sich gegenseitig stützen.
So meistern die Caboussats
ihre schwierige Situation.
Wir machen gerade die Stabübergabe.
Die Übergabe des Arbeitsrocks.
Wollen Sie mal Pause machen?
- Ja, er braucht mal eine Pause.
Seit Jahren bestimmt das Projekt
mit dem Wasserturm
das Leben der Caboussats.
Heute war eine Person bei mir,
die mich gefragt hat, ...
... ob man sich
bei solchen Dingen übernehme.
Ich sagte, ich glaube nicht,
dass man sich übernimmt.
Wir haben vieles geplant.
Aber das Wichtigste ist, dass sich
der Mann und die Frau verstehen,
und dieselbe Vision
und dasselbe Ziel haben.
Ansonsten würden wir wohl
getrennte Wege gehen.
Alleine könnten wir das wohl
beide nicht meistern.
Das wäre nicht möglich.
Ich bin sehr dankbar für alles,
was Mirabelle macht.
Ich könnte das alleine nicht.
Hallo.
* Dianne spricht Kinjaruanda. *
* Sie lacht. *
Auch der Fitnessclub in Ruanda
konnte nur entstehen,
weil Dianne und Marco
an einem Strang gezogen haben.
* Rhythmische Musik *
Rund 100 Abonnements hat Dianne trotz
Corona im ersten Monat verkauft
und konnte so
knapp 2'000 ¤ Umsatz machen.
Das reicht Dianne noch nicht ganz,
um alle Kosten zu decken.
Es läuft viel besser
als ich gedacht hätte.
Die Leute haben Freude,
ihnen gefällt der Ort.
Es ist nahe an der Strasse,
einfach zu Fuss, mit dem Auto
oder mit dem Motorrad erreichbar.
Ich habe Freude daran.
Das ist mein Baby.
Neben Aerobic und Zumba
bietet Dianne auch Trampolinkurse an.
Einen Teil der Fitnesslektionen
leitet die 51-Jährige selber.
Zusätzlich hat sie noch
zwei weitere Trainer angestellt.
* Treibende elektronische Musik *
Choo choo!
Wann immer möglich kommt Marco nach
der Arbeit im Fitnessklub vorbei.
Thank you.
Okay.
* Stimmengewirr *
Hello.
Hallo, Schnuckelchen.
- Hallo.
Der Fitnessclub der Schommers
scheint anzukommen -
trotz Einschränkungen
durch die Coronamassnahmen.
Wir haben ziemlich viele Kunden.
Im Moment dürfen nur 10 % herkommen.
* Er lacht. *
Wir haben leichte Schwierigkeiten,
herauszufinden, wie viel 10 % sind.
Aber wir mussten einfach reduzieren
und dürfen
nicht alle Trampolins aufstellen.
Somit zeigen wir
unseren guten Willen, aber ...
Es ist sehr gut angelaufen.
Ich bin happy.
Ja.
Bald zwei Jahre ist her,
dass Marco und Dianne ihre Heimat im
solothurnischen Bettlach verliessen.
Ich habe bei Null angefangen.
Und jetzt ...
Jetzt läuft es, ja.
Das tut gut.
Aller Hindernisse zum Trotz konnte
Dianne ihre Träume verwirklichen.
Good night.
See you tomorrow.
Und auch Marco konnte sich in Ruanda
etwas Eigenes aufbauen.
Tschüss.
* Sie lachen. *
Bye.
- Bis später.
Schauen wir mal,
wo wir das platzieren.
Schauen wir erstmal,
wie wir es befestigen können.
Dann schreibe ich meine Nummer
drauf, damit sie anrufen können.
Man muss es ja irgendwie sehen.
Als wir es gekauft haben,
war das Schild dort drüben.
Ich würde es hier anbringen.
- Ich schaue mal, wie es aussieht.
So ist gut, oder? Da siehst du es.
- Ja.
Es ist komisch, diese Tafel
an unserem Haus zu sehen.
Ja, es ist ein komisches Gefühl.
(Leise) Danke, Benji.
* Kläffen *
Was? Hm? Ja?
Ja, sag es.
Schwerwiegende Entscheidung
in Spanien:
Corinne und Ralf wollen ihr
Auswanderungsabenteuer abbrechen
und zurück in die Schweiz.
Ihr Haus steht ab sofort zum Verkauf.
Mit dem Homeservice
läuft es eigentlich gut,
aber wir kommen leider
auf keinen grünen Zweig.
Wir müssen zu viel unseres
privaten Ersparten beisteuern.
Das müssten wir
auch noch länger tun.
Aber für den diesen Homeservices,
den wir betreiben,
ist es uns nicht wert,
so viel Geld in die Hand zu nehmen.
Für das Hundehotel
wäre es etwas anderes gewesen,
denn das war unser Traum,
den wir uns erfüllen wollten.
Aber wir möchten das nicht mehr.
Mein Gott, diese Jacken
haben wir hier gar nie gebraucht.
Nein.
- Die sind ...
Dafür müssen wir keine neuen kaufen.
- Ja. Gut haben wir sie mitgenommen.
Ja.
Das tiefe Lohnniveau
sowie die hohen Steuern und Abgaben
machten es den beiden schwierig, ihre
Firma kostendeckend zu betreiben.
Ihre Perspektive:
tagein, tagaus schuften,
weit weg Freunden und Verwandten
in der Schweiz.
Zu Beginn hätte ich nicht gedacht,
dass ich irgendwann
in die Situation kommen würde,
in der ich Heimweh habe.
Auch die Pandemie
hatte einen Einfluss darauf.
Dadurch ist einem bewusst geworden,
was die Familie wert ist.
Möchtest du die noch einpacken?
- (Brummt) Ja.
Noch eine?
Etappenweise
lösen sie hier nun alles auf.
Bis im Frühjahr wollen sie
zurück in den Thurgau ziehen.
Wir habe den Schritt gewagt,
weil dies unser Traum war.
Wer nicht wagt, gewinnt nicht.
Deshalb bereue ich keinen einzigen
Tag, den wir hier verbracht haben.
Es war eine schöne Erfarung.
* Klicken *
Noch die Landschaft.
Ralf und Corinne wirken erleichtert,
jetzt, da sie die Entscheidung
zur Rückkehr gefällt haben.
So.
Wir verkaufen das Haus auch,
weil es ein finanzieller Aufwand
bedeutet, das Haus zu pflegen.
Und das Haus zu vermieten,
ist so eine Sache.
Wir haben schon oft gehört,
dass das nicht das Wahre ist.
Wir hatten auch in der Schweiz
einen klaren Schlussstrich gezogen,
das machen wir hier unten auch.
Wir geben alles weg
und beginnen wirklich neu.
* Nachrichtenton *
Da hat es Angebote in der Richtung,
in der ich suche.
Amriswil - das ist ja noch besser.
Okay.
Die Waldburgers folgten ihrer
Sehnsucht, zogen an die Costa Blanca
und versuchten sich hier mit Mut
und Zuversicht etwas aufzubauen.
Wenn man in diese Richtung schaut -
das Meer spiegelt sich,
es ist ruhig.
Das ist eigentlich schon schön, ja.
Das Wichtigste ist,
dass wir zwei glücklich sind.- Ja.
Alles andere ist ...
- Und dass wir gesund sind.
Ja.
Was ihnen bleibt,
sind schöne Erinnerungen.
Ich teste das erstmal.
Ja, schau es dir mal an.
Ich kann dir leider nicht beistehen.
- Ja, ja.
Falls ich irgendwelche Flossen
sehe ... So ...
Dann rufst du mich.
- Ja.
Bleiben wird ihnen auch
die Gewissheit,
nicht nur vom Auswandern gesprochen,
sondern den Sprung ins Unbekannte
gewagt zu haben.
Der Lärm der Bohrmeissel
im Untergeschoss des Wasserturmes
ist wie Musik
in den Ohren der Caboussats.
Gut.
- Super.
Viel zu lange
mussten sie auf diesen Moment warten.
Wir sind froh,
dass die Leute jetzt hier arbeiten,
dass sie endlich
damit begonnen haben.
Das ist für uns wichtig.
Fortschritte
gibt es auch aussen am Turm.
Die Schäden an den Metallbändern
unterhalb des Wassertanks
waren nicht gravierend.
Mittlerweile sind sie entrostet
und frisch gestrichen.
Jetzt wird ein Schutzgitter
angebracht.
Sollte mal etwas rosten
oder sonst etwas passieren,
fällt es nicht auf den Kopf.
Ein Grossteil der Aussenarbeiten
ist damit abgeschlossen:
Rund 1'000 marode Ziegelsteine
tauschte der Fassadenbauer aus.
Der Blitzschutz wurde angebracht
und es wurden Vorkehrungen
für den Brandschutz getroffen.
Ein Netz schützt die sanierten Balken
vor Taubenkot.
Und die Dachgauben
erstrahlen in neuem Glanz.
Bis zum nächsten Sommer soll der Turm
auch innen fertig umgebaut sein.
Wir haben hier sehr viele
Baustellen, kleine Details.
Aber wir sind guten Mutes.
Wir haben mit der Ausschreibung
der Elektrik begonnen.
Das Einzige, das uns einen Strich
durch die Rechnung machen könnte:
Wir haben zwar Angebote,
es könnte gemacht werden,
aber ob sie dann wirklich kommen,
ist immer die Frage.
Pünktlich zum 125-Jahre-Jubiläum
wollen sie ihr Café im Wasserturm
eröffnen.
Aha.
Der Wassertank zumindest
ist jetzt schon bereit.
Frisch gereinigt und versiegelt
wartet er auf zukünftige Besucher.
Im Rahmen von bezahlten Führungen
wollen die Caboussats den Tank der
Öffentlichkeit zugänglich machen.
Hast du gesehen, der Boden ist
immer sandig. Das ist interessant.
Mirabelle und Alain nahmen ihr
Schicksal in die eigenen Hände.
Für die Vision von Café im Turm
haben sie mit ihren Söhnen
ihr Zuhause im Emmental verlassen.
Ich bin dort zu Hause,
wo die Familie ist.
Wir hätten nie gedacht,
dass wir uns mal
in Deutschland niederlassen würden.
Aber ...
- Vorübergehend.
Für uns stimmt es so.
Es ist wunderschön.
Wir haben hier eine grosse Vielfalt:
vom Meer
über einen solch schönen Wald
bis zu Küste und Schiffen.
Ja.
Und wir haben einen hohen Turm.
Das ist unser Berg.
Wenn wir noch einmal zu
zweit oder mit der Familie
einen solchen Schritt gehen würden,
würden wir wohl mehr Zeit einräumen.
Aber ich glaube,
dass wir das Richtige gemacht haben.
Ja, absolut.
- Das kann man so sagen.
Jede Entscheidung, die wir damals
gefällt haben, war damals richtig.
Deshalb sind wir heute da,
wo wir sind.
Ich würde sagen,
wir haben uns verirrt.
Definitiv nicht. Mama und ich
sind so oft in diesem Wald.
Wir waren wirklich sehr oft hier.
Wir waren wohl schon auf jedem Weg.
- Ja.
Oh, das Meer.
Hast du gesehen, Schätzchen?
Eines ist sicher: Die Caboussats
werden alles daransetzen,
ihr Projekt mit dem Wasserturm
zu einem guten Ende zu bringen.
Wie es aber danach
bei ihnen weitergeht, ist offen.
Ihre Träume verwirklichen, das wollen
auch unsere neuen Auswanderer.
Zur Pensionierung in die Toskana:
Ein Agriturismo ist der kühne Plan
von Eva Dudle
und Philippe Sguaitamatti.
Sehr gut.
- Gut.
Auf dem neuerworbenen Land
pflanzen sie 800 Olivenbäume.
Doch kaum gestartet,
trennen sich die beiden.
Wir bemühen uns
um eine neue Form des Miteinanders.
Der Sommer in Italien ist heiss,
die Gäste kommen,
aber es fehlt an Wasser.
Eine Quelle ist nicht vorhanden und
die andere ist praktisch versiegt.
Wir müssen also nach Wasser suchen.
Ein historischer Moment: Ich drücke
die letzte Schweizer Ohrmarke rein.
Jetzt wird es einem bewusst:
"Ja, wir gehen."
Bauernfamilie Wieser
wandert mit ihren Tieren
aus dem Aargau nach Frankreich aus.
Allez!
Es ist eine andere Perspektive,
eine andere Cashflow-Marge
auf der Milch.
An der Atlantikküste
kaufen sie einen riesigen Hof
und werden zu einem der
grössten Milchproduzenten der Gegend.
Total haben wir rund 460 Tiere
im Betrieb.
Das ist schon eine Hausnummer.
Und endlich ab nach Amerika.
Allgemein war ich schon früher immer
der Indianer- und Cowboy-Freak.
Die Schweiz ist zu klein, sie ist
nichts im Vergleich zur ganzen Welt.
Marina Marrer und Mike Hostettler
ziehen vom Kandertal nach Florida.
Dort wollen sie
ein Waffelrestaurant eröffnen.
Ich zittere schon richtig
vor Nervosität.
Trotz langer Vorbereitung
läuft einiges schief.
Scheisse! Kannst du mir helfen?
# U si stige i Flüger ...
Die neue Staffel ab nächsten Freitag
um 21 Uhr auf SRF 1.
# U sie löh hie aues zrugg
uf dr Suechi für nes nöis Dahei.
# Si göh hüt no uf u dervo.
# Uf u dervo!
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Maria Krähenbühl - 2021